[Música]
tengo muy fresco el recuerdo de ir
camino a prisión
y camino a la cárcel con un amigo
recuerdo cada detalle del camino a la
cárcel de ciudad juárez recuerdo los
movimientos del carro recuerdo el olor
del carro también recuerdo mis
sentimientos estaba emocionado estaba
nervioso y honestamente también tenía
miedo no sabíamos a lo que nos íbamos a
enfrentar ya estábamos cada vez más
cerca y la expectativa aumentaba
no íbamos en calidad de prisioneros y
vamos en calidad de periodistas no sé
cuál de los dos sea más peligroso
una vez que nos acercábamos a la cárcel
empezamos a platicar a imaginarnos qué
es lo que nos íbamos a encontrar ahí
adentro ahí adentro íbamos a entrevistar
a un criminal a un hombre que había
cometido algunos de los delitos más
penados en méxico y en el mundo un
hombre que había asaltado que había
robado que había extorsionado un hombre
que había asesinado un hombre que había
comprado y vendido sustancias ilícitas
y empezamos a ponerle imágenes y títulos
a este hombre que todavía ni siquiera
conocíamos y empezamos a decir seguro es
alto a seguro es alto y fuerte y
empezamos a ponerle títulos seguro es un
hombre amargado enojado con la sociedad
que no se arrepiente de nada de lo que
ha hecho y entonces estábamos tan
expectantes y con tantos títulos de lo
que nos íbamos a encontrar detrás de las
rejas pasamos por todos los filtros de
seguridad y llegamos al frente de su
prisión y pudimos entrar a entrevistarlo
y conforme la conversación fue avanzando
nos dimos cuenta que teníamos enfrente
no a un monstruo sino a un humano a un
hombre arrepentido de lo que había hecho
un hombre que se avergonzaba de todos
los delitos que había cometido un hombre
que sentía tristeza de que sus hijos su
esposa sus padres lo vean dentro de una
cárcel nos encontramos con un hombre que
soñaba
con nunca haber cometido ningún delito
este hombre estaba arrepentido y al
finalizar la entrevista mi amigo y yo
salimos reflexionando y platicando de
que tan equivocados estábamos de los
títulos que le habíamos puesto a este
hombre no era un monstruo era un
criminal inhumano era un hombre
arrepentido de sus errores
y yo no pueda dejar de pensar en cuando
estudiaba la licenciatura en periodismo
la universidad autónoma de ciudad juárez
había un maestro que todos los días nos
decía no le pongas título esa era su
frase todo el tiempo no le pongas título
y yo decía profesor tengo una idea de un
reportaje hazlo pero no le pongas título
maestro yo quiero hacer una entrevista a
la entrevista pero no le pongas título
maestro yo estoy trabajando en una nota
haz tu nota pero no le pongas título y
el pacientemente nos explicaba que
ponerle título a una nota a una noticia
antes de tiempo lo único que hacía era
reducir la perspectiva con la que vemos
algo y nos explicaba pacientemente una y
otra vez que así funciona el cuerpo
humano por eso hay gente que detecta
solo algunos sabores más que otros
algunos olores más que otros de lo que
quiere ver nuestros ojos se enfocan en
alguien o en algo y no ve lo demás
nuestra mente piensa lo que quiere
pensar y no piensa el contexto completo
un ejemplo muy claro de esto es mi mamá
mi mamá me ve y ella me ve alto rubio
hermoso porque ella no está viendo esto
ella está enfocada en mi corazón
esto así funciona el cuerpo humano
estamos diseñados para enfocarnos en
algo y el maestro nos nos invitaba todo
el tiempo a no enfocar nuestra
perspectiva en una cosa nada más que
estuviéramos con la mente abierta al
cubrir la noticia
y entonces
años después terminando la carrera de
periodismo comencé a trabajar en uno de
los periódicos más importantes del norte
de méxico en una ocasión de marcaron en
sábado y me dijeron miguel mañana tienes
que ir a cubrir un concierto domingo por
la tarde de quién es el concierto de
juan gabriel
wow era una gran oportunidad juan
gabriel en esta frontera y yo empecé a
emocionarme y empecé a escuchar su
música verdad y estaba allí preparándome
para hacer una gran nota mi deber era ir
a buscar a juan gabriel tratar de
entrevistarlo y después quedarme durante
todo su concierto en primera fila y
hacer una nota de este evento
pasaron las horas yo me desvelé
escuchando la música y a la mañana
siguiente muy temprano me pongo mis
pantalones de reportero mi camisa de
reportero mi chamarra de reportero no
puede faltar mi gafete de reportero y me
subo a mi carro lo enciendo con su
tanque de gasolina de reportero que
siempre está a menos de un cuarto porque
ganan muy mal los reporteros
y enciendo mi carro y voy a hacer las
tareas del día antes de ir al concierto
y entonces vuelve a sonar el celular y
me jean me llaman y me dicen miguel has
visto las noticias y yo dije claro que
ha estado todo el día escuchando a juan
gabriel no he visto noticias que pasó
pues resulta que juan gabriel murió hace
algunas horas
ya no hay concierto ya no vas a cubrir
un concierto de 3 o 4 horas ahora vas a
cubrir un concierto ahora vas a cubrir
un funeral de 3 o 4 días y entonces
honestamente la noche anterior hice todo
lo que mi maestro me dijo que no hiciera
tomé una hoja de mi cuaderno y empecé a
escribir los títulos que yo imaginaba
que ese concierto iba a tener y los
títulos eran algo así como reconquista
juan gabriel a la frontera llena de
alegría un estadio el divo de juárez y
de pronto con esta segunda llamada me
doy cuenta que esa hoja con todos esos
títulos se convirtió en basura ya no
servían qué habría pasado si yo hubiera
publicado la mañana siguiente en el
periódico uno de estos títulos sabes que
habría pasado sería un fracaso como
reportero sería un mentiroso como
periodista no valdría la pena como
profesional y lo más probable es que mi
cartera como periodista se habría
acabado antes de tiempo
y poco a poco inicia tener la sospecha
de que el principio de no le pongas
título no nada más aplicaba para el
periodismo impreso me di cuenta que
funciona también para la radio para la
televisión para los medios digitales no
le puedes poner título a una noticia
antes de tiempo
tiempo después tuve la oportunidad de
hacer un intercambio cultural como
flotar yo pago para que yo hiciera un
intercambio cultural por un año en
venecia pero yo creía que ya sabía todo
lo que debía saber de venezuela
todo el mundo en ese en ese entonces al
menos yo creía que todo el mundo amaba a
chávez amaba maduro amaba la izquierda y
todos se vestían de rojo porque el che
guevara está de moda no y entonces yo
creía que todos en venezuela eran así
bastó una hora en venezuela caminando
por el centro de caracas para ver cómo
estaban quemando un muñeco tamaño real
con el cuerpo de nicolás maduro y
estaban quemando fotografías de hugo
chávez y quemaban sus playeras rojas de
izquierda en protesta crucero tras
crucero podíamos ver la misma imagen
qué habría pasado si yo me hubiera
quedado con esa imagen que yo tenía de
venezuela qué habría pasado si yo me
hubiera quedado con el título que yo le
había puesto a venezuela cuando eso no
era una realidad y entonces la sospecha
de que no nada más funcionaba
para el periodismo no nada más funciona
para las experiencias de vida me llevan
a sospechar que no le pongas título
también funciona para la vida personal
de cualquier persona porque nos
encontramos con que hay gente
que ha permitido que su pasado le ponga
título a su presente nos encontramos con
que hay personas que han permitido que
su pasado le ponga título a su futuro y
entonces hay gente que va por la vida
caminando con el título del abusado con
el título del rechazado el abandonado el
divorciado el fracasado pero esto no es
un mensaje motivacional también hay
gente que va caminando con el título del
empresario el exitoso el saludable la
realidad de las cosas es que nadie de
nosotros tiene garantizado el día de
mañana ni la salud ni la enfermedad el
que está enfermo hoy nada le garantiza
que mañana va a estar enfermo todavía ni
el que está sano hoy nada te garantiza
que mañana vas a estar sano
nada nos garantiza el mañana
conforme ha pasado el tiempo decidí
dejar el periodismo y comencé a trabajar
en una organización en donde tenemos
como lema que somos una casa para todos
una casa para todos y lo decimos todo el
tiempo somos una casa para todos
pero cuando le pones ese lema a una
organización literal llega de todo ha
llegado gente de todos los colores de
todos sabores de todos los gustos de
todas las nacionalidades
de todas las clases socioeconómicas y me
encanta de todo tipo de pasados y sin
importar todo tipo de pasados que ha
llegado cuando les hacemos entender que
su ayer no define su hoy ayer no define
su mañana su vida cambia
y hoy me encantaría animarte a que
dejemos los títulos que nos ha puesto
nuestro pasado para empezar a ver lo
nuevo que nos puede sorprender el mañana
y sabes gracias a que los reporteros los
periodistas están ahí
hasta el último minuto del partido hasta
la última entrada del juego de béisbol
hasta el último round de la pelea de box
hasta el último voto de la elección que
están ahí hasta que sale el último
herido del accidente gracias a eso
tenemos acceso a las mejores noticias a
las noticias más emocionantes porque no
sé si te has dado cuenta pero las
mejores noticias las que tienen más
reproducciones las que todo el mundo
quiere ver son las más inesperadas nunca
vas a ver en la portada de un periódico
el día de ayer salió el sol
eso no pasa porque todos esperamos que
eso suceda día tras día pero sabes las
cosas más inesperadas siempre están en
primera plana y gracias a que los
periodistas no le ponen título a la
noticia antes de tiempo podemos ver las
mejores noticias cuáles son esas cuando
el equipo de chico en el último minuto
le da la vuelta al equipo grande y sale
campeón cuando el boxeador menos
favorito no queda en el último round en
el último momento al campeón del mundo o
cuando el candidato que nadie esperaba
con un puñado de votos logra ganar una
elección cuando en tiempos de abundancia
la bolsa de valores cae
justo antes de que cierre la bolsa ese
día esas son las noticias más
emocionantes y tenemos acceso a ellas
gracias a que los reporteros esperando
hasta el último minuto como reporteros
no podemos darnos el lujo de salirnos en
el último round no podemos darnos el
lujo de salirnos antes de que termine el
partido
el problema es que en la vida a veces
nos damos el lujo de dar por muerta la
vida antes de que dejemos de respirar
y nos encontramos con personas que no se
han dado la oportunidad de cambiarle el
título a su vida pero sabes si hoy tú y
yo dejamos de vivir con un título y nos
atrevemos a vivir diferente quizá vamos
a poder ver cosas increíbles las mejores
noticias en la vida yo puedo creer que
un hombre de 70 años que se quite el
título de anciano puede ser un
emprendedor
yo puedo creer que un hombre de 40 años
que se quite el título de divorciado
puede atreverse a conocer a una mujer yo
creo que una mujer que se te quita el
título de viuda puede atreverse a
conocer un nuevo hombre yo creo que un
hombre que había perdido los sueños y si
se ha puesto el título de fracasado
puede atreverse a emprender un nuevo
sueño aquella persona que perdió la
esperanza puede quitarse el título desde
estés esperanzado y empezar a creer que
puede volver a tener esperanza
y aquella persona que se puso el título
de atea puede volver a tener fe aquella
persona que se puso el título de exitoso
se lo puede quitar y puede atreverse a
emprender algo diferente aquella persona
que se puso el título de empresario
ganador se lo puede quitar y empezar a
volver a invertir en su empresa
sabes
qué pasó con esa hoja llena de títulos
para el concierto de juan gabriel esa
hoja se convirtió en basura esa hoja ya
no tenía valor y hoy quiero invitarte a
que quizá tú tienes títulos en tu vida
que ya no tienen valor quizás tú has
dejado en la bolsa esos títulos que te
puso tu pasado pero ya no tienen
importancia
ya sabes con esa hoja lo único que se
puede hacer
es romperla porque es basura los títulos
que te puso tu pasado los títulos que te
puso un abusos los títulos que te puso
un error hoy son basura ya no hay nada
que hacer con ellas porque en el
periodismo como en la vida la nota que
está en primera plana no es lo que pasó
hace un año de hace 10 ni hace 20
siempre va a ser más importante lo que
pasa hoy y lo que pasa mañana no le
pongas título muchas gracias
[Aplausos]